hard as it may be to believe nearly a
decade has passed since Steve Carrell
uttered his churlish last words and
walked away from his role as Michael
Scott's a small screen character that
made him a household name but why did
Steve Carell lead the office after
season 7 in April 2010 Steve Carell made
the first public mention that his days
in the fictional Dunder Mifflin office
were possibly numbered he told the BBC
that because his contract for the office
only ran through season 7 the then
forthcoming season would quote probably
be his last year on the series according
to interviews published in Andy Greene's
book the office the untold story of the
greatest sitcom of the 2000s a lack of
internal response to corrals comment
about season 7 potentially being his
last actually made the actor feel like
it was time to leave
Brian Whittle who worked as a boom
operator and sound mixer on the office
explained the sequence of events in the
book Carell was doing a radio interview
and he haphazardly mentioned almost
unconsciously that it might be his last
season he was kind of thinking out loud
but he did it in an interview in public
and it created news then what he said
was the people connected to the show had
no reaction to it
Whittle continued when he realized he
didn't get any kind of response from
them he thought oh maybe they don't
really care if I leave maybe I should go
do other things elsewhere in the same
book hairstylist Kim ferry corroborated
Whittle story further noting that Carell
had told NBC brass that he planned on
signing a new office contract that would
be good quote for another couple of
years
according to ferry however a network
executives simply didn't reach out to
him about negotiating a new deal he
planned on staying on the show he told
his manager and his manager contacted
NBC and said he's willing to sign
another contract for a couple years so
all of that was willing and ready and on
their side honest and the deadline came
for when NBC executives were supposed to
give him an offer and it passed then
they didn't make him an offer
she continued noting that Carell didn't
want to leave the office behind he
simply had no other choice
Carell was like look I told them what I
want to do I don't want to leave I don't
understand it just is mind-boggling how
that happened and I feel bad because I
think a lot of people think he did leave
the show on his own merit and it's
absolutely not true
I'm telling you he really wanted to stay
and it devastated all of us because he
was the heart of our show casting
director Allison Joan called the whole
situation quote absolutely
the asinine since Carell wanted to stay
on the show she stated as I recall he
was going to do another season and then
NBC for whatever reason wouldn't make it
deal with him the office producer Randy
Cordray offered another element that
contributed to Carol's departure the
arrival of Bob Greenblatt's who became
the chairman of NBC entertainment in
2011 allegedly Greenblatt quotes was not
as big a fan of the office as we wished
he would have been portray noted his
belief that Carell likely would have
stayed on the show if there was more
respect coming from NBC for what it's
worth Greenblatt maintained that he
quote couldn't do anything about Carell
leaving the series since he believed it
was already happening before his
promotion why are you the way that you
are honestly like so many television
breakouts before him once Carell left
the small screen he sought to achieve
big screen glory Carol's movie cred has
taken a few hits of late but he still
managed to carve out an impressive slate
of comedic and dramatic projects since
making the switch to movies all the
while he's been boasting a blockbuster
animated franchise with the despicable
Me film series lending his voice to the
villain turned hero through Peck Corral
even claimed an Oscar nomination for his
wildly unsettling turn as John the pawn
to 2014's Foxcatcher it's hardly
surprising that Carell would find such
career success on both big and small
screens the actor didn't officially
break through to the mainstream until
the office hit the airwaves in 2005 but
he'd been plugging away in Hollywood for
years with supporting and creative roles
on TV fare like the Dana Carvey show and
Jon Stewart's The Daily Show as for
Carol's film roles he had already stolen
scenes from the likes of Jim Carrey and
Bruce Almighty and Will Ferrell and
anchorman before claiming the role of
Michael Scott's in 2005 not to mention
his breakout starring role in the same
year with the 40 year old virgin I was
walking down the street and a race car
pulls up and the guy says hey you're
funny you're the funniest guy I've ever
seen or my name is not Dale Earnhardt as
many roles as he's played in the years
since leaving the office behind Carol's
work as Michael Scott's is iconic so
much so that fans and reporters alike
continue to hound Carell about his time
on the series and the possibility of
reprise in his role in a potential
reboot of the show however Carell
continues to shoot down the idea at
every turn he'll be it with loving
insight
he told Collider I know
think we can recapture that same magic I
just wouldn't want to make the mistake
of making it less good version of it
dunder-mifflin any jokes going no not
right now does that mean oh all right
see you around then check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]